Lauren so has the biggest I opener from
making along the roadside been for you
that it all boils down to the P word
which is product right is that the
biggest eye-opener are there other
things it's definitely it was the you
know the the biggest slap you know it's
kind of a I I see but you know necessary
illusions that's one of the things you
will feed ourselves when every day has
charms to refer to and I know somebody
said the film is an art form struggling
to get business and a business
struggling to be an art form and you
know I kind of get it it's um you know
you have to find a way I admired either
burns a lot you know I think he he found
a great way to be a filmmaker Without
Really much interference and dependence
on so many aspects that everybody seems
to be so eager to get a you know handle
on you know where he comes up with a
movie he makes it he you know are you
probably familiar with right and it
seems to be a really great way to go and
I love the fact that he retweeted my
trail Thank You head but you know I
think it's a great time for
up-and-coming filmmakers and it is scary
because the age of abundance is here and
everything's I mean I I listened to some
of you my serving director the same one
who directed film that our actor was a
part of the wampum door he says when I
applied our film icon that year it was
300 movies that's it this year's like
12,000 movies you know so you know and
then there's more people living in the
world so it's becoming now crowded but
somebody did to find that the
intellectual capital is not reproducible
and therefore any sort of media that has
ended with creativity will still remain
as able it will have value of sorts
knowing that product is king are you
going to write your next script be part
of the next project going backwards with
that in mind are you going to do a
horror film with girls of my t-shirts
that are under 25 knowing that that's
going to sell yeah no honestly i won't i
won't it's because if I wanted to do
something I don't love doing you know
there are other jobs you know I mean
there's there are other jobs you know
there's so many other shops but I'm in
this whole film thing not even with my
choice if you think about it with the
whole you know dry comic books and stuff
you know I apparently have this whole
thing I have to do this and I can only
do the films that I can hundred percent
stand behind emotionally and with
everything because I I don't see
anything any other way to do it but that
said I definitely want to be more and
more aware of how what is like the
backhand what's the end of the tunnel
you know I'm a leg is the making of the
film in the final cut is that when the
labor ends no the labor ends when you
make sure that enough people saw the
film and it was worthwhile you know and
in that aspect I definitely want to
explore more of those avenues and be
more aware of it and incorporate that
awareness into the creation of it but I
wouldn't do any film that I wouldn't do
for free if nobody had to say about me
that always remain a row have you
figured out yet what or do you have a
idea of how to find that balance between
art and commerce and that you know so
you're not working on a three-hour
period piece that you're never finished
with and you just keep toying with it
because it's a great piece of art you
know and your heart and souls in it
first is something that you still have
passion for but you know also that
there's a YouTube audience waiting to
see certain actors right now I think as
you said it's it's a good time to get
realistic and greed was never something
that kind of pulled me anywhere so I'm
grateful personally so I always was into
this little talky you know you guys are
our kitchen sink and this is a road film
so it looks much bigger than it by those
are my favorite films like I don't
really get off on big sci-fi you know
this so I do think there I have all
these ideas and scripts and ways to go
about making the cell phones that could
be made inexpensively and if they are
put together the smart way collaborating
with people who do have plugins with
certain audiences it could be one of
those a i do what i love make enough
money so i don't have to you know I
don't know hit the bar tending every
other weekend or something and it makes
sense you know and I think that so
everything one can ask for really to do
what he loves and to be to make a living
off with you know I think Stanford came
up with the study than 75,000 a year
budget happiness and if you made thirty
four thousand a year you're above two
percent of the world as far as rich you
know so like all these Hollywood stories
with pools and stuff you know that's
great but uh you know it's I talk so not
my thing you know and that's nice
you